好的，起步時，幸運有您領先。
見最外檔穿紫色賽衣的是星際快車
欄位置的之星河
外檔的信心星向前推進，中間穿粉紅色袖子賽衣的是美麗第一。
留守於第五。六位的是好友心得。
位於一欄的是友愛心得。絢列倒數第四。
倒數第三、穿紅色賽衣的是翠紅。
倒數第二、穿橙色賽衣的是笑傲江湖，目前落後的是精算景雪。
經過該800米路段
前方領放的馬匹是星際快車。
倒數第二。靠近欄的是幸運有您。
外檔位置的是信心星。
第四位是美麗第一。
欄第五之星河
第六位外檔位置的是好友心得
倒數第四。戴黑色頭盗的是友愛心得。
後方三匹賽駒
戴紅色眼罩。穿紅色賽衣從大外檔透出的是翠紅。
倒數第二。穿橙色賽衣的是笑傲江湖
包尾直路是精算暴香
最後300多米
星際快車仍保有半個馬位的優势
位於中間位置的信心星開始加速。
中檔已打開。
之星河亦在追趕
靠近欄的就是笑傲江湖
中檔位置還有好友心得
最後一百多米處
自馬羣中突圍的是之星河。
精算暴雪持續街上
位於中檔
之星河仍先機
外檔緊追精算暴雪
獲勝的馬匹是之星河
靠近欄
檢視是否有機會奪得沙田銀瓶
持續追趕
精算暴雪確實緊追多匹。
後方的賽駒
好友心得於中檔位置跑至第三。
第四名靠近欄
星際快車
之星河似乎可捧走今沙田銀瓶，
錯。精算暴雪山來遲，跑過第二；
好友心得跑過第三：星際快車都跑過第四。
推進小步亦不可，因步步緊迫，即精暴雪。
財寒亦已落後，步速由精算暴雪控制的是星際快車。
雙方